There are so many small companies who've been devastated this year.
We have not seen a sustained attack on mom and pop shops. Uh,
like we've seen in 2020,
who are innovators and making something happen.
And when you're just like one dude, who's producing a product,
they're a sponsor of mine. I'm happy to. First of all,
it's funny that I'm pitching underwear, but ha pitching.
But it's also something I enjoy small business.
It's microscopic like a thimble. So this isn't a sponsor of mine,
but this is a good segue. So this is Russians.
We celebrate new year's none of them go at them. We have the Edmodo was,
he comes down, puts a president under your pillow.
So this is a company called JL Lawson. He's a fan of yours. He's a metal worker.
And he said, can I give you something to give to Lex?
I have one of his worry coins. I'll tell you what it is. He's not a sponsor.
This is not, I'm not getting paid for this.
So what a worry coin is I carry around in my, but if you have rod denim,
it's great because it brings you fades.
So you carry it around with you all the time. It says,
worrying is like paying a debt. You don't owe. Right?
And I carry this around and it's been like a year.
Next time you're worrying. And this is good advice.
If you don't have a word coin,
go think about 10 years ago and what you were worried about then,
and then think about did any of those things pan out? And some of them did,
but you were able to handle it. And that's a good way to maintain perspective.
So JL Lawson's the company. He sent me this president. I said,
let me give it to Lex on the air. So enjoy, sorry. I also open it up.
Yeah. J L Lawson and co two Lex from Anthony. Yeah.
And I said, make something mathematical for Lex.
I don't even know what's in there. You don't know what's in there.
And it got through TSA. It could be a bomb. It could be.
Just like this episode.
Sure. You and rabbit close to the mic as a dress for crazy.
That's really the best thing.
Or is this what unboxing video looks like?
This conversation's going to be a big hit on the internet.
Boxing community.
I need to have an excited look on my face to make sure the reaction video is
being unboxing and a reaction video.
Lex Freeman reacts. It's another box. It's just a series of boxes.
Lex, big fan. Since hearing you on Rogan months ago,
most of your guests are over my head, but still enjoyable.
Like this episode,
Michael was kind enough to want to share my work with you.
Keep doing what you do, Anthony Lawson. Thanks, Anthony.
There's a lot in there. What is it?
Okay. All right. Am I done by the way?
Sure. Show it to the camera and then make sure you look excited or not. No,
this is cool. This is a worry coin. Like I was showing you. Oh,
so you hold it in your hand and when you can do this with your thumb,
if people are, have anxiety or whatever, or there's a lot of cool stuff in here,
Fibonacci coin. Oh see. Yeah. That's the math stuff. That's really awesome.
This is really cool. Wait, you got a big one landing there too.
That's what she said.
I'm telling.
You last time you offended me saying I don't have humor.
Uh, the spin tray, micro brass and copper bronze.
By the way, the packaging is Epic. I think that's his top.
He makes tops.
Cool.
Spin it in there. And Institute two different, uh, bronze and copper.
I think.
The only one who makes these machine tops and then three sitting here, I guess.
Yeah, but you could spin them in that step. That section. Okay. Got it. Cool.